Now let's go and proceed a bit systematically. The situation we are in is classical.
We do have a program and the program gets some input and out pops a failure
that can be seen by the user.
What is a failure in here? A failure is an error.
An error that's externally visible that is visible by the user.
What is an error? An error is something that deviates from what's correct, right, or truth.
Errors are typically unwanted and unintended. Failures are error. A defect is also an error.
A defect, however, is somewhere in the code.
The defect is what turns otherwise valid input in the end into a failure.
The term defect is an error in the code as in several synonyms.
Some people also called this a fault but then a fault can also be applied to data.
The by far most common word for defect, however, is of course, bug.
There is a bug in my code somewhere as if this had somehow crawled in into my code.
Here is this foreign but, this is my code, it doesn't belong here. That's okay.
In the end, it's us programmers who are actually introducing these bugs in there
and so are very much prefer the term defect.
The aim of debugging is to find the defect that causes the problem.
For this, I want you to look a little bit deeper into how a program actually executes.